first of all let me simplify something
there's not a single person in the world
that doesn't show off but here's what
came up hey he's showing off good and
that wasn't in this stage the
conversation came up later on it's
showing off good it's a good to show off
it's about to show off and so you know I
had this question asked several times
and people say you know what I'm gonna
start showing off anytime this person
shows off and it works for them so I'm
gonna do it and said I should I show up
should I not show up and you know you
know showing off is bad it's immoral
it's not Christian it's not the right
thing to do you know you should never
show off you should be this person and
have a lot of you know virtues and just
be to yourself and be righteous and and
why would you show up I never like
people who show it off their nice cars
and their homes and all this other stuff
they're missing something they have a
certain level of insecurity they're
hiding something
you know people that drive yellow cars
and red cars and orange cars and purple
cars you know they're making up for an
insecurity in a different place in their
lives you already these things I mean
this is the the stuff that we hear about
right when somebody says why are you
showing up first of all let me simplify
something there's not a single person in
the world that doesn't show off not a
single person the most noble person
shows up they're just showing up their
nobility mother Teresa showed off you
know what she showed off she showed up
law love but that was her show off she's
showing up how much she loves people her
showing off was I don't need a $10,000
dress just give me a five-dollar thing
to put around me and I'm happy that's
showing up but it's a different kind of
a showing off well Pat not I disagree
with you let me make my point you can
disagree with me all you want I'm just
making my point and if I don't make
sense don't listen to me you don't have
to listen to what I'm saying I've just
given you a different perspective the
people that drive a Ford Focus who don't
like others who drive Ferraris you'd
like to show off their 6-pack there is
show off a girl who gets up in the
morning and says I don't like people to
show off their big homes but spends 45
minutes doing makeup that's showing off
look good okay when we get up in the
morning and we look good and we shave
and we don't leave any hair and we're
just kind of like trying to take care of
ourselves our skin you know we're trying
to show off in a different way hey this
is what I look like this is my product
this is who I am now
maybe those are not the things because
if you look at the definition up it
means to deliberately a brag about what
you have that maybe better of somebody
else something you know a lot of
professors show off their knowledge
politicians are masters of showing off
their opinions their ideas you know
wealthy people show off through their
lifestyles sometimes a pastor shows off
their level of a knowledge about the
Bible you know a you know an educator is
gonna show off their the level of
degrees and you know you go to their
office how many offices have you gone to
musi degrees of people and they show up
you go to their office the professor has
I got my MBA from Wharton Business
School and I got my degree from Harvard
and I went to USC and I went to Florida
State and I went to SMU and I went to
this but let me tell you something you
know this Trump guy all he wants to do
is show up and I don't think it's
healthy for society to show us I don't
think there's a single president in the
world that wasn't a show-off I mean
that's the party guys got to realize